- So Alyson, (audience cheering)
I'm loving this like,
American Pie reunion.
- Me too!
- But here's my question. (laughs)
- Yes?
- Do people still
walk up to you and say
this one time at band camp?
- Yes they do, which is
lovely to be associated
with the movie people still know,
but I have two daughters now, and,
(Audience and Kelly laugh)
When they're with me, and
they like, somebody starts,
- People don't follow through, right?
- Saying the line, I'm like
could we just stop there?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like yes.
- Like, I'm not, I get really panicked.
- [Kelly] Of course.
- And I'm like, yeah yeah yeah
I know what you're talking about.
And, they know.
- [Kelly] Like yeah, yeah,
- [Alyson] Yeah, please stop,
(Alyson is drowned by Kelly)
- Really funny, yeah.
- I don't want to have
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
this conversation with them yet.
- I've never thought about that,
cause you have kids that's.
Well wait, you have kids
too there, so like wait,
when it came out did your kids see it?
- No,
(Audience, Alyson and Kelly laugh)
no my, daughter was 12, and so that,
- That's a little early.
- That's that's a little early.
My son was 15 and he was going to,
come with us, in Los Angeles,
we went down for the premiere,
- Yeah.
- Of the movie.
And the night before the premiere,
he said, he was on the
phone call with his friend,
back in Toronto, and they
said well what's going.
He said, "Well I'm going to
the premiere of American Pie,
tomorrow night with my
folks", and the friend said,
"Oh, don't see it with your folks".
(Audience, Alyson and Kelly laugh)
"Don't see it with your folks,
- [Kelly] Bad news.
- You don't want to
see this with your folks."
(Kelly laughs)
So he came to us and said, "You know what?
"I think I'm not gonna go tomorrow,
(Audience and Alyson laugh)
"and I'll see it when I go back
to Toronto with my friends."
And I said, and I thought, "Oh well okay,
"it's gonna be a big night."
Meanwhile, we went to the
premiere, saw the movie,
I'm so glad he wasn't there.
(Audience and Kelly laugh)
- [Alyson] Oh, oh yeah.
- That's so awkward.
- Oh yeah, oh yes.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.